all right everett
where'd you go where are you from
originally well i'm originally from
virginia um my dad was a pilot so we
only lived there one year
and then uh we moved to south florida
and that's that's where i grew up like
until i was in high school with florida
south florida really beautiful what city
um melbourne beach
um
fort lauderdale del rey beach yeah
and i went to high school in melbourne
same high school as uh
james morrison from the doors
how was your childhood my child i grew
up really fast um
like i said my dad was a pilot so he was
gone a lot
our mother was um a bunch young much
younger than my father
and she was a model she she was on the
cover of a couple magazines in the early
80s
and uh
she would leave my older brother and i
who was only four or five at the time
at the house to go out and party
obviously in south florida
and um
i just can remember
one of my first um things i remember
was seeing a white pile of powder on the
table and then when i was in high school
at a party and i saw the same thing and
it brought me back to when i was a
little kid you know
and uh i always said growing up i would
never
you know never could do what she did
like i would never want to treat people
like she did but
you know obviously uh things changed and
i went from
making
money doing that thinking i'm the good
guy to
falling in the traps of it too
what can i get for you in high school
um high school i was a good i was pretty
good kid i was a good pitcher in
baseball
um
actually really really good all-star
team um
i learned how to throw a knuckleball
from a
guy who would eventually become a future
hall of famer tim wakefield
and he went to fyt
and i was in high school and he taught
us how to fill the knuckleball and so if
i would have stayed on straight and
narrow
i probably would have been drafted like
a few of my friends were drafted one of
them went to the dodgers
but um by my senior year i was getting
loaded before pitching games
yeah
and after after you're done with school
you went where
um after high school
well i still i tried to play baseball
for like a year but i was i was getting
loaded at the time
and um i stayed in florida and i went to
uh
[Music]
fort lauderdale community college
and uh i did all right i've always done
pretty well at school
i enjoyed literature and um speech class
and all that
psychology mostly writing was like i was
horrible at math
i don't know why my brother was great my
dad's pilot so he's obviously good but i
would try so hard in math
for hours and get a seed and i wouldn't
try in writing and get an egg
you know so that was my thing but um
heist um community college is where i
first got introduced to fast money
as far as south florida goes and um
just fell into the same thing some of my
other family members were doing
started uh
driving you know
christmas gifts and birthday gifts and
packages up out of state
at a young age around a very young age i
had a lot of money so you started with
dealing before you started yeah big time
yes and the dealing left led to using
the dealing glad to be using i started
um
guys using my own supply
knowledge cocaine it was ecstasy that's
what i started with was ecstasy because
i would go to like just raise with
christmas gifts for the dj's or whoever
they were and
they were so much fun it was hard to
like not try half a pill you know i was
like oh wow i mean eight people having
sex this is great you know
and uh i wasn't even 21 yet i wasn't
even 21 i couldn't even really drink
and i was you know going to private
parties in miami
and uh
so ecstasy is what it's weird like most
people start with weed i started with
ecstasy you know it's a hardcore drunk
dude
really hardcore
and what is your drug today my drug
today has moved on to more pain
self-medicating type stuff um
uh heroin china
fentanyl
sometimes crystal meth if i'm really
tired i have to do something
or just it's you know
people call it coffee people i know
they're like you got a shot of coffee
you know but um
mostly um a daily daily uh
self-medicating with uh fentanyl and
china white yeah
where do you stay now
um where do i say wow that's a great
question um where did i stay last night
um if you just you move around
[Music]
um you wing it yeah i do i've stayed
when i first became
without a permanent address
i was much cleaner
and much better doing things than
getting things so i was staying
sometimes in bel air
sometimes in beverly hills overnight
with older women you know whoever it was
that was friendly with me
and um
as you get more and more living like
that it's so hard to maintain
people don't realize for people
how hard it is to maintain
just looking halfway [ __ ] decent
um
just to be able to go out in society
without the luxuries of having
warm water and stuff like that every day
it becomes harder and harder it's really
like
most people i don't know how i've done
it for as long as i have but most people
that's one thing most people don't get
it's the daily challenges of just
maintaining
halfway what society expects yeah so so
like for example last night or this week
you're you're just staying where okay
last night i stayed in the tent
at the lovely macarthur park right um
with a couple buddies
and um
is this
rock bottom for you
oh this is below rock bottom
this is um
this is the high highs and the low lows
are just
a constant medium to low low
high highs don't even work anymore um
you know
until i get a 38 foot boat
you know in a slip somewhere and i'm
actually not stressed
it's just until i get to that point or
something like that it's a fairly
it's a daily battle and uh
i've actually was in the army and i've
been to battle
and my feet were in better condition
than they are now
yeah this is a very stressful lifestyle
it's it is and then people if somebody
says it's not then they're not fully in
on the concrete yeah as we call it you
never really get a break from anything
do you nothing at all you don't get a
break from anything i mean
god forbid i go to whole foods and buy a
sandwich and try to sit outside and eat
it i guess they can just tell they're
like you can't sit here sir like
what do you mean i just bought a sure
don't start with me like
well i'm just trying to eat my lunch
dude like sorry i don't have an office
to go to right now but um
no there's no break that's john i
haven't had a break in forever
a break is like if i'm not out and i can
yeah somebody doesn't wake me up for
half an hour yeah and then it's an
amazing break but then you get robbed
when you do that of course yeah i've
lost everything oh i haven't
it's crazy story had
oh i hate to say this this hurts um
i mean this is tough man
[Music]
ugh
before my grandma passed away
i went back to florida
i was doing well at the time i had a
full-time job
i was in college
i had done some background work and
pelvis
i was first i thought about this
she gave me
something if she said i could take care
of it
and they were my great grandmother
then i rescued her baby slippers
from
philadelphia from like 1880 or something
i had it for two years
in my back on the street
and then when somebody stole that bag
from me
that was the end of it like it was like
i got lucky for two years
every day on the streets made sure
nobody couldn't
somebody doesn't know
what they took from me
[Music]
it was the last thing
my granddad had passed away for years
early
they were great they were great people
and they always believed in me
i remember
i had gone on the gold mine to pasadena
i had a bag full of stuff that had
gotten you know picked up to survive
and maybe headphones you know
gucci sunglasses i don't know what it
was
but like i said i always had these
slippers with me when i didn't have a
permanent place
and
what somebody took
who knows if they threw them away they
were just these little brown
they almost look like native american
type slippers but
the last time i really said to me
i'm gonna give this to you because i
know you'll take care of
it
them
as small as it seems to some people
i was given everything i've ever had to
just tell the person just let me keep
this you know
that was my connection
to a better day
and uh
sometimes people don't know you know
they just steal things from other people
that are vulnerable
and i remember i was tired
and i remember that feeling when i woke
up and somebody had taken this that was
from me
it was like the whole world stopped and
i just remember looking up and down the
train
thinking if i see somebody that i think
took this right now like
they have no idea what they're in for
like
i've seen it done enough to where this
person's not gonna make it off this
train
um
but there was
nobody around it was just like me on on
this train
so whoever did it got a few nice things
and they got this little box with
babysitters that means nothing to
anybody but
for my grandmother to still believe in
me at that time
and say you know i'm going to give this
to you to call out to him
great grandmother grandmother
grandparent's father to me
mother
and i'm the one who
living in this lifestyle
was so tired
i accidentally fell asleep for a few
minutes
somebody stole it from me
that was like two or three years ago
it's weird i don't think i ever cried
about that so i just now thinking about
it like
i just brushed it off even though i
thought about it a lot i just brushed it
off but
that was tough you know that's something
that's
like i said as small as this to some
people
it was like my world my world
you know connection to
everything i had was like
pictures and all that you come and go
but that was something you know
you know
sorry thank you
that's i'm sorry too yeah the symbolism
is i hope somebody
said stolen game to their grandmother or
somebody and just said look what i found
or something somebody has them you know
because
they mean something to me
they're probably for sale in some thrift
shops somewhere that's what i'm thinking
you know the antique store for probably
five dollars
yeah i know
i mean i i can't argue i can't
i had a few antiques that i sold over
the years
so i can't say i wouldn't have sold them
if i got them but
that's the thing some people don't
realize is
you could take something that means
nothing to you from somebody
because you see a product purse or gucci
sunglasses or whatever it is that you
get off on
and some dirty little slippers
somebody would give you a pair of good
sunglasses every day to keep those
slippers you know
so that was tough man
do you have any friends
yeah i i consider myself um
[Music]
i do have a few friends yeah i mean
i grew up with some close people i have
an older brother and stuff and um
but i've gotten off social media i can't
put on a front
and live a fake life like hey look at me
i'm doing great you know
walk of fame you know some [ __ ]
like tell me about your posture what's
going on with your back
this just started like a year ago and
it's i'm six foot four
you know it's like
the concrete does something to you after
a while
that just um
i don't know i just it sucks
that's what i can say about my postures
it's horrible so you haven't
i haven't gotten enough treatment on it
or whatever i i know i should go to the
i'm one of those people doesn't ask you
for help man i'm really bad
and i can go to the va hospital and get
help but
i'd rather get out and think i'm
tough guys hustling and making money and
supporting myself
but um
yeah i'd love to be straight up again
and walk straight like my grandad would
tell me stand up straight boy
you know and stuff and
i always did but i guess for four and a
half years now on the concrete
and that's
80 years probably for most people in
daily walking that's part of the stress
of yes
my i've been to the hospital
once in those one half years because i
literally couldn't walk another step
i had to have surgery on my foot and
have my sock
one of my socks had grown into my foot
oh really yeah that was horrible when
you have seven surgeons pointing at your
foot talking about it it's not good
going wow look at that oh interesting
like no
you know but they they helped me a lot
you know they tell me that was hollywood
presbyterian
have you been in love before
yeah i've been in love before
i was in love um
in high school once
was a beautiful girl and um
[Music]
and then once out here i had a good life
out here for quite a few years after i
got the army
i um
community college
and uh background acting
i've i'm a i'm a writer and i've written
with some people um i have a few friends
that have gone on to do you know
gigantic colossal
projects um oscar type stuff and
that's another reason i got off social
media and all that because i don't want
them to feel sorry for me you know
i'd like to come back one day and do
stuff again
you know
what do you what do you worry about what
do
you
what are you afraid of
other the one thing i do fear
is that when i do pass or something it's
going to be in this life style
and to me that's that's losing because
it's
you know
people think it's cool or whatever
i'm so past like i've never did this
because it was cool
i never
was like trying to be like that i just
i did survive
everything i've done is survival i never
had
somebody i could call and say hey
pops can i borrow 500 you know for this
or
nothing i'm um
not that i am
bitter over that i'm not at all i think
it's great that people have
families that they can
reach out to for help and all that but
um
i just fear that
i won't reach the expectations that i
had for myself even as a kid
even as a kid you know like
i don't want to um
like i say man if you get sober for a
couple days
and you
die after being sober for 12 days for me
you won because you had a couple days
sober as painful as it might have been
at least you weren't
a [ __ ] to
the medicine and to the to the booze and
to whatever else
you needed to cope
with with daily grinding you know like
does your family know you're
like i said my
my grandparents passed on and they were
really the foundation for me um
my mother was the drug addict and stuff
i haven't talked to her in 25 years
um i still don't i don't hold that
against them
and then my father was a pilot
and he went on to do other things
and um
you know
the area where i lived in florida
there was a few other families whose
parents were pilots
my one friend john and his dad died with
you know i think it was like
i didn't know until high school but my
mom and his mom were friends
and his mom his father passed away
um as a pilot leaving in a runway and
the plane was too heavy and uh
like you know big
kilos of cocaine in his plane
and those were the circle that my family
my parents were in so
um
connections with them have been long
gone
i don't hold it against them at all
actually um because i had my
grandparents
but when you raised my grandparents at a
young age sometimes they pass
so
so you've been living like this for how
many years now
um like this about four and a half to
five i believe
although numbers are screwed up how was
it
um
1980
so
40
yeah four something else
i started this at like 36 i think yeah
until then i lived um in the valley in a
two two-story condo
i had a cheap cherokee
i worked um
normal jobs
full time 40 hours plus
i had a top secret clearance for a while
shredding
on confidential paper in
the federal building for the fbi and
like you know not that i worked for them
but i still
i was a very normal person at the time
you know badges
stuff like that but i always fell back
into uh
maybe like a
i don't want to say pity party because i
never did it like that you know i always
didn't have fun and feel good
but um like i said
there's no more high highs anymore it's
all medium to low
you know
what do you think was the biggest factor
in you
changing you know
taking this route for the last five
years
i've done a relationship before that and
she
put up with stuff that maybe some people
wouldn't
um
i didn't drink every day and stuff but
when i did
it was like okay i've been working i'm a
good guy i've been working for one
straight
let me take you know leave my wallet at
home because i know myself let me take
fifty dollars and go to the bar
that was never the case
you know that fifty dollars turned into
500 on as soon as i drank enough drinks
the liquor would turn into
drugs
and um
it wasn't like when i was young and i
was making money selling drugs and all
that
nowadays i was working like a normal
person so i had to buy them
and boy did they get expensive fast you
know
um
[Music]
i think just that relationship ending
i still got an apartment by myself for
three years i had it i fell behind in my
rent
i think it was two months
and i was locked out
with just like two bags
way around the valley
with a broken down car
and that was when i just hit the ground
running as far as survival
and started doing everything i had to do
and um
it was okay for like two or three years
i was doing great i was making money
like you know big time
supporting myself doing what i had to do
but that takes a toll on you after a
while
takes a toll on your posture to pull on
your looks yeah how do you think it's
changed your
your mindset and your personality being
on the streets for five years
um
i like to think that i've always
felt for people that are in these
situations
um at least after i was like maybe as a
kid i'd be like
in a drug addict you know my mom was one
or whatever but
i think i've always had a spot in my
heart for people like that but now it's
people that that um
judge
those people
or people that like have dirty hair and
dirty beard and dreadlocks and
if they could just walk a little bit in
those that person's shoes
that person wishes more than anything
that person would just
doesn't have to give them anything you
know and go to fly sign and say help me
just don't look down on them or
because they don't want you to look down
on the most of them they just want you
to live your life
and not you know get scared when you see
them most of them just want to be
halfway normal or be left alone even you
know
they've been put down so much
and a lot of times like
people aren't even allowed to walk in
the stores
like i've been stopped
walking in this door before
i'm told i can't shop here a story i've
never been to
that's so so
hurtful and it makes you really angry
too
because you're thinking to yourself wow
you know this guy's telling me i can't
shop here and
i have more education than him and more
money and
in my pocket than he does but i can't
come inside
you know it's um it's opened my eyes to
a lot of things
like i said i don't feel sorry for
myself or anybody else but
you know don't kick people when they're
down
because down is down down down far and
it hurts
and a lot of them just want to be
halfway normal you know just
and
so they i don't need anything but still
run away from me or something you know
and you don't realize what they went
through as children and stuff like that
oh you have no idea the things that i
mean not
i have no idea myself what some people
go through
and hear some people's stories
you know that um
[Music]
yeah i mean like
being chained up in like a basement for
two years and
had your body
you know victimized day after day and
then do you have kids no i don't that i
know
i mean i say that just because i've
traveled a lot i've been other places
but
um i don't know
i was in this trip for eight years
and we never had kids
and um
that was probably closer i came to being
like you know that type of life
but i always had one foot sort of going
out the other way
you know
what is your biggest regret
my biggest regret
i don't think i've hit that yet because
there's still things that i want to do
and there's still things that i want to
be able to
i used to say
this will be i'll be back in your house
and apartment
soon i'm going to do this i'm going to
help people
and help others you know the cliche or
whatever
but um
[Music]
to say i have i i
my biggest regret right now
is uh
to say that i i have a regret i guess i
don't know i don't
i still try to do the best i can every
day even without nothing that i have you
know
and um
maybe you know using in high school and
not pitching more
um
maybe moving away from the ocean because
i used to surf
and that was such a great lifestyle and
i was really good
and uh i miss the ocean every day
i miss surfing
[Music]
um
you know that's a spiritual aspect that
i did for years and i was really good at
it
um
yeah that's that's uh i went to venice
beach like five years ago
[Music]
my friend didn't believe me that i grew
up surfing and i was the best person in
the water and surfing like seven years
and it was you couldn't believe it
so that's one thing i regret is not
living by the ocean
yeah yeah sorry
yeah
cliffhanger and ever what would you say
is the most important thing you've
learned in your life
i always have a tissue
you got two yeah i know thank you sir um
[Music]
the biggest thing i've learned
in my life
what's the most important lesson
always
always believe in yourself
in another person and other people and
don't
as bad as humanity is and how f'ed up
these people are
there's still some good ones out there
and uh always if you want to be on that
good side no matter what people tell you
you are
not just
flying flap what anybody says
and i've done things to survive
but i'm not on the bad side
and um
i just believe it's don't give up on
yourself
and to say that right now
is unbelievable because i should have
given up years ago
you know how i haven't given up yet is
is um unbelievable
but i i do believe that
um
[Music]
that there's still a day out there
that's gonna come where i'm gonna
go you know it ain't that bad down here
you know
all right everett thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you i wish you
the best of luck thank you
you